[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans dimanche
en politique votre émission de un débat
en franche comté nous sommes ici en
direct de la cour du musée du temps et
de la place granvelle de besançon à
l'occasion des 24 heures du temps on va
se poser une question toute simple
l'horlogerie comtoise est elle de retour
comme au bon vieux temps comment sortir
de l'ombre du prestigieux voisin suisse
le succès de notre or logique de notre
horlogerie passe-t-il par l'innovation
ou par la tradition ces questions vallée
posée à nos quatre invités je vous les
présente tout de suite d'abord pierre
alain bérard vous êtes responsable de la
marque flip fondé en 1908 et de nouveau
exploité en franche comté au sein de la
société démontre bisontine basée à
châtillon le duc également sur ce
plateau williams berthet ingénieur
conception à berthez horlogerie une
manufacture qui a le label entreprise du
patrimoine vivant et qui fête cette
année ses 130 en vous êtes installé à
charmes hautvillers et à villers-le-lac
dans le haut doubs sur ce plateau aussi
sébastien thibaud enseignant à l'école
nationale supérieure de mécanique et des
microtechniques lensel également vous
travaillez également à l'institut
femto-st vous former en quelque sorte
les horlogers de demain et vous
réfléchissez aussi aux montres de demain
et puylaurens agen averti du secteur fin
connaisseur de l'horlogerie vous êtes
directeur des études économiques et
territoriales à la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie du doubs spécialiste du
secteur de l'horlogerie bonjour à tous
les quatre merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation comme d'habitude vous pouvez
vous aussi participer à cette émission
en la commentant sur les réseaux sociaux
avec le modeste qui s'affiche dit mme
paul fc comme dimanche en politique
franche comté alors messieurs
la franche comté est généralement
considéré comme le berceau de
l'horlogerie
française monsieur bérard ma question
est simple est-ce toujours le cas on
peut dire que c'est toujours le cas oui
là la franche comté c'est toujours le
plus gros nombre d'emplois de
l'horlogerie française est de loin et
puis on reste au niveau des sous
traitants très très présents même par
rapport aux voisins suisses on garde un
vrai savoir-faire que les capitaux
soient français ou suisse monsieur
berthet il ya une grosse crise dans
l'horlogerie est ce que on peut parler
de renaissance véritablement aujourd'hui
alors de renaissance oublier non il ya
eu plusieurs crises et la crise de
2008-2009 qu'à poser des problèmes à
toute l'industrie de manière générale
mais à l'horlogerie également récemment
un peu plus récemment il ya eu des
problèmes notamment au niveau de la
suisse lors de lors du changement du
cours du franc suisse quand il était
presque à parité avec l'euro ça pose
aider énormément de problèmes à notre
voisin et donc indirectement à nous et
récemment donc il y a deux ans et eu un
problème
dernier problème au niveau de la suisse
mais là c'est en train de revenir petit
à petit donc il ya un nouveau des
emplois dans le domaine et c'est donc on
sent on sent que ça revient on va y
revenir évidemment dans cette émission
mais d'ores et déjà clairement c'est la
suisse qui donnent le ton dans ce
secteur
de toute façon le voisin est vraiment
très proche donc on ne peut pas faire
sans eux
probablement que sur certains cette part
du marché ils peuvent faire sans nous
mais on est aussi indispensable
leur fonctionnement sur certains points
sébastien thibaud vous n'êtes pas franc
comtois d'origine
est-ce de la flagornerie quand on dit
que la franche comté
c'est le fer de lance de l'horlogerie
française absolument pas c'est
effectivement le cas la franche comté
est vraiment associé à l'horlogerie
française et internationale la plupart
des pays d'ailleurs reconnaissent
besançon pour l'horlogerie et la
microtechnique et particulièrement
l'horlogerie qu'elle berceau des
microtechniques et encore aujourd'hui
oui c'est le berceau et c'est là où il
ya également comme on vient de le dire
le plus grand nombre d'employés et des
formations alors beaucoup de formations
mais il existe des formations horlogère
à l'extérieur de la franche comté mais
notamment en en ingénierie est également
en horlogerie est un très grand nombre
de formations qui existent le greta vous
allez me c'est la guerre faure de
morteau
vous avez également des que l'école qui
forme des ingénieurs par des horlogers
mais des ingénieurs aussi bien en
apprentissage que en formation initiale
et un certain nombre de nos étudiants
finissent dans le secteur horloger
suisse dans certains cas est également
français voire internationale vous je le
disais vous n'êtes pas de la région à
l'origine vous êtes venus ici parce
qu'il ya ce savoir faire
oui alors les scènes mais les iem et une
école particulière dans le sens où la
premier rôle de lenssens kaneko
nationale d'horlogerie et cette école a
évolué au fur et à mesure du temps
notamment à évoluer notamment avec la
crise de l'horlogerie
puisqu'avec la crise de l'horlogerie ont
formé des ingénieurs qui à l'évocation
notamment être d ordre des ingénieurs
pour l'horlogerie
sauf qu'aujourd'hui les années 70 et 80
l'effondrement de l'horlogerie notamment
par l'arrivée de logerie à quartz et
bien a fait qu on a dû changer nos
formations
néanmoins on a toujours eu ce fil rouge
or liés à l'horlogerie
laurence âge on parle de l'horlogerie
comtois ce qu'est ce que ça représente
économiquement parlant ce secteur
d'activité alors c'est plusieurs choses
c'est on a parlé de sous traitance on a
parlé de marques horlogères
on peut parler des gens qui sont à
l'écosystème de formation aussi c'est
environ 2500 3000 personnes sur la
franche comté alors ça se concentre
beaucoup bien sûr sur le bassin de
besançon le pays horloger et le haut
jura
il faut aussi citer les travailleurs
frontaliers puisqu'en fait sous très
nombreuses et un bataillon énorme de
l'horlogerie suisse aujourd'hui il ya à
peu près 55 mille salariés dans
l'horlogerie en suisse dont un tiers de
frontaliers français et parmi ces
frontaliers français y en a environ
15000 qui sont francs comtois et qui
ramène aussi beaucoup d'argent
économiquement c'est très important pour
la franche-comté évidemment alors c'est
très important ça représente de l'ordre
de 1 milliard et demi d'euros en termes
de salaires chaque année vous parler de
l'importance de la suisse vous parler de
la sous-traitance est ce que ça veut
dire que on est ici en franche-comté
dépendant entièrement de la suisse pour
ce qui concerne l'horlogerie
grosso modo oui on peut le dire c'est
rien rien ne peut se faire sans un
regard sur la suisse sur ce qui
fonctionne là bas sur ce qui fonctionne
moins bien et s'inscrire en creux par
rapport à un certain succès ou certaines
difficultés suisse
ça a beaucoup de sens maintenant on a
aussi une autonomie dans notre capacité
d'innovation notamment sur les marques
je pense à la renaissance de la marque
jeep typiquement ça ne dépend pas de la
suisse à dépend beaucoup de nous enfin
de vous monsieur verra monsieur
verhaeren vous confirmez vous vous êtes
développer sans forcément regarder ce
qui se passait de l'autre côté de la
frontière
premièrement effectivement s'est
développée sans regarder ce qui se
passait
l'autre côté de la frontière puisque
nous avons les ressources sur la
franche-comté seul et pour j'irai
clôturé sur le voisin suisse les montres
suisses med sont fabriqués en majorité
par des jeunes français qui s'est fait
tôt le matin des jeunes français des
jeunes françaises qui se lèvent tôt le
matin qui passent la frontière et qui
vont donc fabriqué ces pièces de l'autre
côté de la frontière donc le savoir
faire il est au corps dans la région
simplement ils se lèvent tôt le matin il
prend sa voiture pour aller
travailler en face mais est-ce que ça
c'est pas un échec de notre tissu
entrepreneurial à nous alors on va pas
se voiler la face oui euh
c'aurait été mieux l'histoire est ce
qu'elle est et effectivement il aurait
été préférable que les emplois restent
dans la région
les suisses ont su faire le dos rond et
conserver ce savoir-faire avec
l'explosion de leur tour des grandes
marques suisses dans les années 80 90
2000 ou le mécanique est revenu revenu à
la mode et c'est ils ont survécu donc à
la crise du quartz une société comme
l'ip effectivement est passé à travers
de dépôt de bilan avant de renaître
aujourd'hui mais moi je suis persuadé
que pour répondre à la question de
l'émission on voit tout un tas de jeunes
entrepreneurs bisontin franc comtois qui
refont des choses refonder très belles
choses des nouvelles marques qui se crée
et
on assiste je pense honnêtement on
assiste au renouveau de quelque chose
aujourd'hui
sébastien thibaud vous qu'il est formé
en partie les futurs horloger vous
confirmez
aujourd'hui partout vos élèves une fois
diplômés ne va pas le cacher c'est la
même manière quand il parle dans
l'horlogerie puisque nos élèves ne sont
pas que ne sont pas formés que pour
aller dans l'industrie horlogère ainsi
une grande partie qui va ça peut varier
entre 20 et 30% par promotion gros le
gros avantage de nos élèves c'est qu'on
léon les ans les formes mais on les
forme est également à être ingénieur et
ne pas être horloger et ce qui peut
faire une différence en suisse qu'ils
ont aussi une vieille histoire ils ont
une capacité à refaire des choses très
innovante mais toujours en gardant leur
histoire et leur fonte de mode de
fonctionnement et on voit beaucoup de
nos jeunes également revenir ça c'est
aussi un point à dire qu'on vient de
dire ici à part de l'entreprise qui se
remonte et notamment des jeunes qui sont
partis dans l'industrie horlogère suisse
et qui veulent faire autrement et qui se
réimplantent hills est ce qu'on leur a
appris
ils ont la culture franc comtoise à
culturesfrance haine et ils ont une
capacité d'innovation être en rupture
potentiellement avec des choses qui
peuvent se faire en suisse william verte
et vous vous êtes sortis d'écoles
récemment il ya un ou deux ans je crois
il ya deux ans et vous avez été formé et
où j'ai suivi une formation en suisse
juste de l'autre côté de la frontière
malheureusement mais c'était une
malheureusement n'ont heureusement pas
dans votre école mais c'était donc une
formation d'ingénieur microtechnique
avec spécialités horlogerie et pourquoi
avoir choisi la suisse plutôt que la
france pour la formation c'est mieux
réputé en suisse qu'est ce que c'est la
proximité géographique puisque vous êtes
dans le hockey quels étaient les
critères de votre choix
pas spécialement là
la renommée de la suisse mail
de manière générale ça s'est fait comme
ça c'est je pense la proximité la
proximité j'habite à morteau et là
l'école en suisse et dans laquelle je
suis allé à durant une partie de la
formation était à neuchâtel puis au
locle donc à 10 minutes 10 minutes en
voiture pour pour eux le type de
formations qui savent tu aurais pu être
à besançon c'était plus proche pour nous
mais la qualité est la même laurent sage
s'affranchir de la suisse c'est possible
c'est toujours difficile en tout cas
fort pour tenir compte
quoique on met le doigt sur un point
c'est finalement il n'ya pas tant de
reloger que ça dans l'horlogerie
d'accord la plupart des gens qui
travaillent dans l'orgie sont pas
relogées ils vont être logisticiens ils
vont être ouvrier assembleur poseurs
d'aiguilhe micro technicien beaucoup on
pourrait citer aussi lycée jules haag
côté du lycée de porto sur ce registre
là donc il ya des batailles ont géré les
gens qui ne sont pas relogées et même
mon que probablement que la part des
horlogers d'affaires à 5 % dans là
dessus horlogère mais ce foisonnement
vous le constatez parce que vous vous
avez une hauteur de vue sur le secteur
économique horloger le foisonnement des
marques là le ce qui se passe en ce
moment de ce côté-ci de la frontière
c'est anecdotique où il ya un réel
mouvement
c'est vraiment une réalité on est
contacter régulièrement par des gens qui
ont de très bonnes idées qui alors on a
la capacité de fabriquer des montres qui
sont en partie française qui peuvent
être suisse aussi qu'ils peuvent être
labellisé suisse mais tu sais la
difficulté aujourd'hui c'est de l'est de
les vendre
tellement les bouleversements dans la
distribution sont énormes
on pourra en reparler on va reparler
vrai mais on a tendance à dire donc que
la suisse donne le ton que ça repart
vous vous le constatez aussi le le robot
j'ai cru qu'on manque que vous mettiez
en doutent parfois le les chiffres
avancés par la fédération alors
horlogère suisse
alors peu de gens expriment ce sentiment
de remise en question des chiffres
suisses sur le fond on voit bien que le
salon mondial de l'horlogerie le
baselword est en difficulté aujourd'hui
donc c'est quand même un des symptômes
de 2,2 de cette filière il a perdu la
moitié d'exposants en un an était
réduite deux jours 30% de distributeurs
en moins qui visitent ce salon pour
c'est quand même ce n'est pas une mince
affaire
il ya un autre salon qui qui qui se
développe c'est le salon de la haute
horlogerie à genève
alors on peut penser que c'est un jeu de
vases communicants en fait c'est pas le
même concept est pas là mais en place
est symptomatique
c'est symptomatique d'une crise qui
perdure est contrairement à ce qu'on
nous raconte clairement clairement alors
est ce qu'on peut parler de crise moi je
prends ça pense à parler de non pas de
reprise parce que crise reprise mais
plutôt de est ce que c'est une
résilience à nouveau de la douceur le
gère comme elle a eu comme elle était
capable de le faire plusieurs fois avec
de nouveaux codes notamment en
distribution de suivi des clients de
capacité de réparer les montre aussi les
services après vente
quand un peu négligé globalement à
l'échelle de la filière où il se passe
quelque chose c'est une crise aussi
forte que celle des années 80
probablement oui allez dites nous ce
qu'on constate pour pour rebondir
le marché est en train de changer au
niveau de la distribution vraiment est
en train de changer au niveau de la
distribution
c'est tout simplement internet qui
internet
présent dans notre travail depuis très
longtemps mais des phénomènes nouveaux
comme les marques les jeunes marques qui
naissent sur kickstarter
nos distributeurs sont en grande
difficulté nos distributeurs sont
grandes de dernière seconde alors nuit
on n'achète plus forcément démontre dans
les boutiques
aujourd'hui on achète plus les monts
dans des boutiques et le marché est en
train de se restructurer et
effectivement
je pense que la distribution va vraiment
souffrir dans les années qui arrivent et
nous par ricochet aussi le il ya un
grand changement face à nous c'est à
dire que vous par exemple pour leap vous
êtes à fond sur la tradition le vous
remettez au goût du jour une marque qui
est qui est très forte mais il faut
aussi innover et pas forcément que dans
les mécanismes que dans la montre il
faut aussi innover sur la manière de
vente c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre
c'est mon point de vue il peut être
débattue mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui
c'est le plus important aujourd'hui
c'est le plus important on est présent à
l'export sur des marchés qui n'existait
pas il ya cinq ans on est présent à
l'export sur des marchés avec des
réseaux de distribution qui n'existait
pas il ya oui il ya à peine cinq ans une
montre sur deux qui se vend en asie
puisque l'ip est présent à l'export
uniquement en asie
une vente une montre sur deux qui se
vend en asie serré
sur internet et avec des réseaux qui
n'existe même pas en france comme dd com
wbi au one shot
c'est des choses qui qu'on ne
connaissait pas il ya trois quatre ans
on parle d'avenir et d'innovation
reviendra au mode de vente mais monsieur
thibault le on parle beaucoup des
montres connecté on a pas mal de
questions là dessus
est-ce que c'est aussi un domaine dans
lesquels forcément la recherche doit
investir alors c'est déjà le cas il ya
déjà des projets en cours et des projets
qui démarre ce qui paraît au fond c'est
un exemple de l'industrie horlogère
suisse pour entreprendre et où ils ont
mis du temps est ce ce créneau dessus il
il ya plusieurs segments aujourd'hui de
la montre le monde connecté en est un il
ya aujourd'hui aussi dans un segment sur
la menthe connectés et mécanique
mais les deux en phase parce que tout
simplement
aujourd'hui le cadre dynamique qui peut
se payer une montre un peu haut de gamme
est aussi intéressé par une montre
connecter pour ses activités
professionnelles
donc ça c'est direct et de recherche on
a des choses qui sont démarrés là dessus
d'ailleurs dans le cadre de plusieurs
projets et ça se développe
effectivement mais il faut être en
avance également sur ce segment
vous vous travaillez sur une plateforme
de recherche qui s'appelle mots mais cac
est soutenu à hauteur de plusieurs
millions d'euros par la banque publique
d'investissement notamment ses ambitions
le votre objectif ses relances et
l'horlogerie haut de gamme en france
le made in france ça veut dire encore
quelque chose c'est un argument de vente
pour l'horlogerie repense forcément la
suisse là c'est encore un argument de
vente à condition de ne pas copier la
suisse parce que je pense que la france
a tous les arguments de vente à tous les
arguments de vente
effectivement pour montrer qu'on a des
capacités d'ingénierie d'innovation les
matériaux les procédés la façon de
concevoir des systèmes qui peuvent être
différents par contre si on essaye de
copier effectivement envoyé le collègue
suisse à côté de nous on n'a pas de on
n'a pas réellement de créneau là dedans
william berthet la montre de demain
on y réfléchit aussi forcément même
quand on est une entreprise quatre cent
trente ans mais justement je voulais
rebondir sur l'aspect montreux connectés
je pense que enfin en tout cas me
concernant on travaille quasiment
exclusivement sur de l'horlogerie
mécanique et je pense vraiment que c'est
un créneau complètement à part qui est
vraiment peu impacté par la montre
connecté parce que la montre en soi est
un objet qui à notre époque ne sert plus
n'est plus utilitaire il est plus un
objet d'apparat qu'on va nous rapporter
pour parce qu'il est jolie partie et
c'est élégant et le montreux connecter
plus justement dans l'aspect utilitaire
est pour l'instant à mon avis encore
trop peu trop peu exploité les
fonctionnalités qui sont sur les montres
connectés si c'est pour avoir les mêmes
que celles sur le téléphone c'est pas la
peine donc il faut aller chercher plus
loin notamment j'avais entendu un moment
d' entendre parler du médical à voir la
montre qui peut donc testé le pouls à
travers la transpiration donner des
informations qui seraient importantes
mais pour vous c'est pas essentiel
d'aller sur ce terrain là il ya un
créneau aussi pour les montres
traditionnels oui je pense que c'est
laid je pense que c'est vraiment deux
créneaux qui qui ont peu de choses en
commun
sébastien d'abord le projet monica
financé par la banque d'investissement
et qui regroupe 1 3 laboratoires comtois
et puis un arbre au coeur de metz et
puis plus entreprises locales
principalement l'activité sur leurs
lancements l'horlogerie mécanique
puisque l'objectif est de reproposer des
composants innovants ou des procédures
ication innovants sur des composants
pour l'horlogerie mécanique
laurence âge je vais vous faire réagir
une citation d'un patron de grande
marque
c'est carlos rosillo le patron de bell
ross il nous dit personnes à l'affût
formule magique le luxe à l'heure du
digital est encore à inventer
oui alors j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer d'ailleurs une époque
moi je crois que la montre connectée est
l'arbre qui cache la forêt du numérique
d'accord la numérisation elle touche on
en a parlé la distribution
et c'est là que les enjeux le combat est
immense finalement la moins connectée va
peut-être plus menacé les 950 millions
de montres à quartz produit chaque année
et pas les 25 millions de montres
suisses lui dont d'ailleurs seulement 7
millions de mécanique 1 je suis
entièrement d'accord le le montre
connectés menace la montre à quartz est
là et pas du tout la montre beaucoup
moins la montre mécanique c'est à dire
qu'on est comme disait william berthet
sur un objet de décoration que ce que de
payer une montre mécanique ça avant tout
un bel objet c'est avant tout quelque
chose de statutaires et excusez moi
messieurs mais est ce que le grand défi
c'est pas aussi les nouvelles
générations les jeunes portent pas
forcément de montres est-ce que là
dessus vous n'avez pas un un immense
défi à relever un immense défi à relever
et il faut pas minimiser l'impact
surtout des géants du secteur au niveau
de la monde connecté puisque la mode
connecté en fait vous avez deux géants
qui représentent 90% du marché on va
passer on va pas citer les marques est
effectivement une fois qu'ils ont pris
la place au poignet le défi pour nous
c'est que les gens se réapproprient
plaisir de la montre mécanique alors
dire moi je le vois sur mes étudiants
par exemple beaucoup d'étudiants
aujourd'hui leur grève c'est d'abord une
montre mécanique au poignet donc il ya
quand même un objet jolie l'objet joly
est liée à la région à d'ailleurs
l'historie cieux l'objet facile allez-y
laurent sage sur la question du
numérique je pense la bona c et
culturels on le constate le milieu
horloger est un milieu de mécaniciens et
d'ailleurs
ça c'est une vraie difficulté culturel
c'est-à-dire que le numérique n'est pas
dans la culture horlogère et les
avertissements coup qu'on a tous vécu en
2008 au moment de la grande crise
financière qu'on menace et l'horlogerie
haut c'est à ce moment là ont été
masquées par dix ans de croissance en
chine pour l'industrie horlogère et
finalement entre temps le smartphone
envahi notre univers et ça sent
l'horlogerie suisse est donc aujourd'hui
on voit des tentatives extrêmement
variés je dire parfois un peu désespérée
dans cette terre marque tous être
présents sur internet
elles sont déjà sur amazon sans
forcément le savoir voyez donc on est
sur un problème culturel
les recrutements en suisse actuellement
dans l'horlogerie cd data scientist des
webmasters des animateurs de réseau
c'est typiquement le la recherche de ça
donc le défi du digital c'est à la fois
pour la montre en elle même et pour la
distribution comme on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure un scellé de suis entièrement
d'accord le le gros du des ficelles ça
va être la distribution la numérisation
de la distribution book est d'aller le
taux d d'ailleurs des marques de luxe
horlogère
suisse qui investissent déjà les réseaux
sociaux qui font des événements sur les
réseaux sociaux ici mètres même si c'est
pas du tout dans la culture il y a
aujourd'hui des marques qui ne sont
présents que sur internet et des marques
qui s'en sorte qu'ils vivent très bien
aller on a eu quelques questions par
internet je vous en livre une c'est
d'ailleurs une réflexion d'abord d'eric
qui nous dit hormis l'état
les seuls mouvements que nos chers
manufacture achètent sont asiatiques qui
cite si goulée miauton je me tourne vers
vous yota par exemple ces japonais les
utiliser pour pour votre montre star on
va dire oui
parmi les grands pays de l'horlogerie
vous avez la suisse vous avez la france
et vous avez japon zaiko est né à peu
près en même temps clip et
la qualité des mouvements japonais et
n'est plus à prouver
elle est on est sur ce qui se fait de
mieux au monde et je vois pas pourquoi
on s'interdirait de travailler avec ces
gens là savent ailleurs ça sert à rien
de faire du 100% made in france ou six
coups très bien à la recherche ser vite
équivalent ça va au delà pour
aujourd'hui on en est pas capable je
vais m'adresser à l'ancienne en
l'enseignant chercheur juste à côté de
vous on n'allait pas capable aujourd'hui
car aussi bien on n'est pas capable de
produire en tout cas aujourd'hui un
nombre conséquent de mouvements qui
permet de rendre notre hymne et
d'amortir le process de fabrication
néanmoins le projet momies etc a
démontré sa c'est ce que nous allons
nous allons démontrer d'avoir une
entreprise étendue donc de regrouper les
compétences nous tendre une entreprise
pour présenter des possibilités d'avoir
tout ou partie d'un mouvement mécanique
qui sera mis à disposition notamment
l'envié de l'industrie française
donc c'est un développement non le
projet bien déterminé mais l'objectif
est de proposer sa de suis juste
totalement d'accord avec ce point de vue
là aujourd'hui les mouvements japonais
sont très fiables et très reconnue c'est
même pour moi les meilleurs mouvements
qu'on puisse trouver sur le marché
néanmoins
néanmoins l'idée c'est de pouvoir
proposer ce genre de choses là william
berthet sur cette concurrence asiatique
donc plus sur l'aspect de
du sample du made in france plutôt que
de la concurrence asiatique s'est voulu
parler de du fait que pour je connais
pas c'est bien le marché des mouvements
à quartz mais pour les mouvements
mécaniques
c'est aujourd'hui impossible de faire un
mouvement 100%
construit en france mécanique tout
simplement parce qu'il ya des savoir
faire notamment au niveau de tes de
l'échappement toulouse qui est au niveau
du balancier échappement et l'excision
n'existe pas vous avez vos propres monte
mais vous fournissez au bout aussi
beaucoup d'éléments notamment pour des
horlogers suisses ans oui et notamment
les boîtes de montres de poche kiné qui
là c'est le contraire c'est qu'en suisse
ça n'existe pas un fournisseur de boue
entre deux mondes de poche tel qu'on en
fait les choses sont vraiment
interconnectés oui c'est le même
écosystème l'un sans l'autre on est sur
l'arc jurassien d'un côté français de
l'autre côté suisse les choses sont
interconnectés et il ya des savoir faire
qui sont d'un côté des savoir faire qui
sont de l'autre tout ça fonctionne
ensemble et l'un sans l'autre ne
fonctionne pas il nous reste quelques
secondes démission une toute dernière
question alexandre vous demande comment
ne pas réitérer les erreurs que par le
passé on a fait une fois que notre
territoire doit retrouver toute sa place
dans le domaine de l'horlogerie
laurence âge à quoi va ressembler
l'horloge de demain on sait je rejoins
ce mode est dire le cias est dans une
logique d'arc jurassien franco-suisse la
victoire entre guillemets sera sera
partagée d'un clairement merci beaucoup
à tous les quatre d'avoir participé à
cette émission
mercier évidemment aussi à la brasserie
le grand mail qui nous a accueillis ce
matin on est sur sa terrasse évidemment
jusqu'à ce soir n'hésitez pas à venir
participer voire les très beaux objets
exposés pour ce cette cinquième édition
des 24 heures du temps dans un instant
votre flash d'information en région et
puis au dimanche en politique continue
avec francis letellier qui reçoit ce
midi aurore bergé la porte parole des
députés
la république en marche je vous souhaite
un très bon dimanche n'hésitez pas à
venir ici place granvelle et dans la
cour du musée du temps à besançon bonne
après midi à tous merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]